- [Instructor] What we are
going to do in this video
is talk a little bit about lipids.
Now, a lot of times,
lipids are strongly associated with fats,
and that's not incorrect.
Fats are lipids,
but not all lipids are fats.
A better definition or
a better association
for lipids would be a class of molecules
that you often see in biological
systems that are not so
water
soluble.
And I didn't say outright hydrophobic,
which means not attracted to water,
because there are definitely lipids
that have parts that are hydrophobic,
that are trying to get
away from the water.
But there is other parts
that are hydrophilic,
that like the water,
that would be attracted
to water molecules.
Now, in terms of roles
they play in the body,
and we can think of fat molecules here,
well, they definitely play a role
in terms of energy
storage.
Whenever I look at my belly,
I just like to think of all that energy
that is there covering my six-pack.
They could be involved in signaling.
In future videos, we're
going to study hormones,
and hormones are nothing but molecules
that help transmit a signal
from one part of the body
to another part of the body.
And many of these hormones are lipids.
They're also involved in membranes.
So a lot of the time in biology,
we're gonna talk about cellular membranes
and how they're formed
with these phospholipids.
And we'll see these
phospholipids, in particular,
have one end that's trying
to get away from the water
and another end that is
attracted to the water.
And that's actually what
makes them good for membranes.
Just going back to fats,
let's actually take a look
at what some of these
lipid molecules look like.
So this right over here is
an example of a fat molecule,
but the general structure
you're going to have is
these three fatty acids.
So that's one right over there,
one fatty acid,
two fatty acids,
and three fatty acids
that are connected to a glycerol.
And don't worry too much
about the words here.
You'll study them more when you get
to an organic chemistry class.
But that's where this word
triglyceride comes from,
tri- for your three fatty acids
and -glyceride from a glycerol.
And triglyceride is, in
fact, another word for fat.
And what makes a triglyceride
not so soluble in water?
Look at these long hydrocarbon
chains where you just
essentially have a bunch
of carbons and hydrogens.
Those parts, remember, things
that are soluble in water,
they tend to be polar molecules,
things that have a partial
charge on one end or another
or even a full charge.
But when we look at
these hydrocarbon chains,
they tend to not have
these partial charges on
one side or another,
and so that doesn't make
them so soluble in water.
And another word that you sometimes hear
associated with fats,
saturated or unsaturated fat.
That's really referring to what's going on
on these hydrocarbon chains.
If the carbons are as bonded
to as many hydrogens as they can,
well, then you're talking
about a saturated fat.
It's saturated with hydrogens.
If it's not bounded, if it,
in theory, it could bond
to more hydrogens because it
has some double bonds in there,
well, then it's unsaturated.
Maybe in a future video, we'll
talk about the health issues
of saturated versus unsaturated fat.
Sometimes in popular
culture, fat gets a bad name
because everyone's trying
to get their six-packs
or whatever else, but it's
very important to realize that
without fats you would die.
Many vitamins, which are
not so soluble in water,
making them, in fact, lipids,
need fat in order to be
absorbed into the body properly.
But as I also mentioned,
all lipids are not fats.
Here are more examples of lipids,
and I'm not gonna go into detail
into their molecular structure.
But you see something similar here.
They all have long chains of hydrocarbons
that aren't so soluble in water.
These parts right over
here would be hydrophobic,
hydrophobic.
But what's interesting, especially
about this sphingomyelin,
which is involved in your
myelin sheath in the brain,
it helps electrically insulate neurons,
it's also involved in membranes,
it makes up a substantial part
of the phospholipids in membranes,
is that this sphingomyelin right over here
has a part that actually is hydrophilic.
And as we'll see later on,
that's what makes things,
molecules like this,
phospholipids, this is
a sphingophospholipid,
makes them good for membrane structures.
Because the part that's
attracted to the water
could be on the outside,
and the part that's not
attracted to the water
could be on the inside.
And so you can form these membranes
that a cross-section of which
would look something like this
where the circular parts
are the part that want,
the parts that want to
be around the water,
while these tails right over here,
these are the hydrophobic chains
that want to go away from the water.
And this is, in fact,
what cellular membranes actually look like
if you were zoom really,
really, really far in.
I'll leave you there.
Between lipids, carbohydrates,
proteins, nucleic acids,
we've really covered
the major macromolecules
that you will see in biological systems.
Once again, what makes
them macromolecules?
Well, they can be composed
of many, many, many, many, many atoms.
They aren't small molecules.